it's my pleasure
to introduce neil de swani
neil is the co-director and the
co-founder
of the stanford advanced cyber security
program he is an accomplished technical
visionary
angel investor internet security thought
leader and he served in a variety of
research development teaching and
executive roles at organizations from
twitter and google to yodle and bellcore
he was the chief information security
officer at lifelock and at symantec's
consumer business unit
he's also the co-author of the book
security foundations what every
programmer needs to know and next monday
he has a new book coming out
called big breaches cyber security
lessons for everyone in my understanding
it's already hit an
amazon bestseller list in the uh cyber
security
in the cyber security category so as i
always say neil is really
uniquely positioned as both someone
who's been a practitioner in the field
for a long time and really understands
it from that perspective
as well as an educator he's really in
that unique position
able to give us a great overview of the
cyber security landscape
and with that i'm going to hand the
presentation
over to neil thank you pax very much for
that introduction i'm thrilled to have
all of you here today
uh glad to see hundreds of people in the
audience for this webinar
i am going to be talking about key
takeaways from recent cyber attacks
and what i'll do is go through a number
of different
cyber attacks from over the years up
through the
recent solarwinds hack
this past december and tell you about
what might be
some cat you can take away
so to just tell you a little bit about
some of the different breaches uh
there's a whole bunch of different
large organizations that have been uh
hacked and breached over the years
i'm going to be commenting on a number
of them target jpmorgan chase opm
uh up through capital one and solarwinds
i will
spend more time ideally on the
more recent ones over the past few years
namely
the ones at facebook equifax mariette
capital one and solarwinds
but i do think it's important to sample
from some of these mega breaches i also
will be presenting
data on not only some of the mega
breaches but on the 9
000 reported breaches that have taken
place to date
but we're we're not here to just uh you
know talk about
the bad news uh and what we can learn
from it uh
i'm going to be spending a little bit
time talking about
the the seven habits of highly effective
security so
for those of you that are familiar with
stephen covey's work on the seven habits
of highly effective people
my co-author for the big breaches book
um cyber security lessons for everyone
and i we basically thought about what
are the seven habits
that are are necessary to follow
if you want your organization to achieve
security
so i'll talk about i'll sample from a
few of those habits we of course go into
much more detail in the book
and then i'll talk about some technology
defenses that you can use
to address the root causes of breach and
i'll spend time talking about the root
causes as well
so that will give you a little bit of a
sense for what we're going to cover
over the next say 40 45 minutes
and then i'm looking forward to taking
some q a at the end so please get your
questions in
our team at uh the stanford summer
professional development is combing
through all the questions
uh identifying great themes amongst the
questions and i'll do my best to address
as many of those in one shot as i as i
can
so first if we just look at some
statistics
from over the years we can see
that from the period of 2005 to
about 2009 there were on
average a few hundred reported breaches
every year and i should mention that
california was the first state to pass
a data breach notification law back in
and that's when data started coming in
even though there were also hacks and
breaches before then
because of the law it uh gave
more visibility into a number of these
hacks and breaches and so what we see
from the year from 2005 to 2009 is it
was mostly organized cyber criminals as
the internet and the web started getting
used for more and more electronic
commerce
cyber criminals realized that there's
ways to make money
by duping folks and stealing data and so
we
saw many of those kinds of attacks and
even in 2005 there was a little bit of a
concern
and a growing concern amongst government
organizations
that foreign nation state adversaries
were getting into the business of
hacking and breaching
uh companies and what happened in 2009
was that there was a nation-state
um suspected nation-state sponsored
attack
called aurora that impacted google as
well as three dozen other companies
google was the first to kind of come out
and talk about it
but what we saw after 2009 was there was
a market increase in just the number of
breaches that were getting reported per
year
and so if we look at the stats from 2010
up until 2018 2019
we see that there was almost a doubling
in the number uh in the average number
of breaches that were reported per year
and where we are now here in 2021 we're
coming off of
the 2020 december 2020 discovered
hack of solarwinds in which
nine government agencies
in addition to about a hundred private
companies
have been have been hacked and uh well
let me also mention that while
that hack is is referred to as the
solarwinds hack
uh solarwinds was just one of the
company's hack there was
approximately 30 percent of victim
organizations that didn't even use
solarwinds
so we'll chat more about that in detail
in a few minutes here
but that's some of the stats just around
number of breaches
that are getting reported let me also
mention that the legal definition of
breach
is when somebody's name and
sensitive identifiers about them are
inadvertently exposed or stolen
there could be all kinds of system
infiltrations where
trade secrets and intellectual property
and all kinds of other things get stolen
but uh may not necessarily constitute a
reportable breach
that said many organizations especially
if they're public organizations
and they uh care about maintaining trust
with their customers and consumers
they very often err on the side of of
reporting
uh security related issues um and we'll
see that
uh in some cases there are some breaches
where
for instance yahoo when all three
billion of their
accounts got breached the security team
at yahoo actually knew about that back
in 2013 or 2014
but it didn't get disclosed
until 2016 and there's more fun to chat
about there
uh while while there has been
um increases in the number of breaches
that have taken place on a per year
basis
from the previous stats we see that
there was it was a stepwise increase
so if you're any company say oh there's
been an exponential
you know increase in the number of
breaches that's simply not true but
what what is true is that the number of
records that attackers are able to steal
in each breach has been increasing it
has not only been increasing
but it's been increasing in a super
linear fashion uh that doesn't
necessarily mean exponential that
doesn't mean
i mean polynomial but but definitely
increasing the subliminal way so this
graph here
shows the number of records
that have been getting stolen in a
number of these breaches you see that
going up and to the right and the the
yahoo breach
you know especially prior to
the solarwinds was clearly
the largest breach that had taken place
in the history of the internet
in which all three billion of their
accounts got got exposed
uh and uh even though the solarwinds
hack has been
very significant uh the question is how
do you how do you measure the impact of
that actually just this past friday
there were a number of uh hearings uh
taking place um at the
uh at the at the highest levels of
leadership
uh with the with the joint committee um
for the department of homeland security
and uh
and and whatnot that you know analyzed
all the all the breaches so how are all
these breaches happening why are they
happening what are the causes of all
these breaches this graph here
shows some of the causes as categorized
by
a database from privacyrights.org
of the 9000 breaches and while it may
look like
hacking or malware is the largest cause
of
breach with the highest
bar here the second bar uh from the left
uh there's some other causes that i
think are also notable so
you see that there's a pretty high bar
for physical loss
certainly over 1500 breaches and there's
also a pretty high bar for unintended
disclosure
which is uh the third bar from the
from the right and there's over 1500 of
those as well
why are why is physical loss of say
devices or unintended disclosure or even
portable devices when portable devices
get lost
or stolen why are those breaches well if
you have data on media whether it be
paper or data
on such devices and the device gets
lost or stolen if there is unencrypted
data
which has people's names plus sensitive
identifiers about them
that enjoy that basically results in a
reportable
breach and if you if you add up
things like physical losses plus
portable devices plus unintended
disclosures
the number of breaches due to those
reasons is actually
larger than hacking or malware or
organized cyber criminals or
uh you know or nation state attacks
and so what this means is that for
security or organization one of the
first things you should do is just make
sure that uh file vault is turned on on
macs bitlocker's turned on on windows
that you employ not only storage level
encryption but application layer
encryption
for all sensitive data on your servers
so that
when when those kinds of issues occur
they don't just automatically
result in reportable regions encrypting
data is a very very good thing and
uh dan bonnay uh who's uh
one of my fellow co-directors he's one
of the the
the world's uh luminary authorities in
that area
uh so so you know we have we have
courses on
on um how to use cryptography correctly
to encrypt things i encourage you to
check that out
so so so going on though let me then
now focus on hacking hacking and malware
and so i have
i have um this slide here which
shows unencrypted data as the most
prevalent root clause of breaches
but there's a number of other very
important root causes as well
so phishing malware third party
compromise or abuse
software security vulnerabilities and
inadvertent employee errors
make up the root causes of breach for
those of you that are in the field and
you're working to comply with a whole
bunch of security standards whether it
be
pci to take credit cards hipaa to
protect healthcare information
uh stocks if you're a public company
fedramp if you're doing work with the
government there's there's tons of these
security compliance standards and they
all have many hundreds of check boxes
you have to check
but what i want to highlight in this
slide is that while there are many many
such check boxes
the counter measures that you have in
place for these root causes
i would argue are more important with
regards to
avoiding getting breached as opposed
to just showing your good hygiene good
security hygiene through
compliance so i think in some of the
stories and histories of the breaches
that i talk about you'll see these root
causes at work
and i'll bring them to life as much as i
can here
so um you know these next two slides
have a table that summarizes some of the
biggest breaches that have taken place
and what i'll do is go into details on
some of them so i'm not going to really
spend much time here on the summary
slides
but let me rather just get into some of
the stories here
so one of the first mega breaches that
that took place was back in 2013 when
target the retail chain of stores
got breached they had 40 plus million
credit card numbers stolen
and it was the first breach where
ceo and the chief information security
officer were fired i think prior to 2013
most companies thought about cyber
security as
an information technology issue but in
the aftermath of the target breach
it became clear that security and cyber
security is not just
a information technology affair
when things go wrong it's not just the
chief information security officer
that gets fired it's not just the chief
information officer that gets fired the
ceo can get fired too in fact in
target's case
not only was the ceo fired but the board
was sued and there were tons of
lawsuits that the the company faced
uh the costs in the breaches were
upwards of 250 million
and you might be interested in how did
how did it happen
well the way the target breach happened
is that they had a third party by the
name of fazio mechanical services that
was responsible for the heating and air
conditioning
of all of the target retail stores
and pharmacy mechanical services
had network credentials stolen which the
attackers used
to then pivot into target's
network so third-party compromise was
one of the root causes here
once the attackers got in they started
sending out a whole bunch of phishing
and malware attacks
and the attackers were able to pivot
from
the uh systems uh from the network and
foster mechanical services
into the point of sale stations
at all the retail stores because they
had a relatively flat network there was
no segmentation between different parts
of the network and the more
network segmentation that you have the
better so that if one part of your
network say gets compromised
that doesn't mean that attackers can as
easily shift into other parts of the
network now target had
actually bought 1.6 million dollars of
firearm sensors to detect malware
and those sensors were alarming they
were going off
their alerts were getting processed by a
team in india and those alerts were
getting escalated but there was
so many of them there was so much noise
that they couldn't get escalated and
acted upon
fast enough also the categorizations for
the malware were pretty
were pretty generic and so
uh it's important to not only have the
defenses have the defenses well tuned
enough
so that ideally every alert is
actionable and that you don't have false
positives that simply generate enough
noise
so that you can't delve into the real
issue so so that was the
synopsis of the target breach and
major major takeaway from that it made
cyber security
a board level issue cyber security is
not just an i.t issue
one one final thing that i'll mention
about the
target breach is that it was the first
of many
third-party compromises that took place
so you're in security we have this
saying that you're only as strong as
your weakest link
and if the weakest link is one of your
suppliers if they are tied into your
network if they have
access to data then they can very easily
be used to compromise your
main organization too uh the very next
year
jpmorgan chase one of the top banks
in the country got breached and by the
way
let me mention that in the target case
what was stolen was credit card numbers
so not the not the worst thing in the
world because you can
change credit card numbers and it may
incur some cost
but the the effective credentials that
were stolen can be
invalidated and you can give people new
ones uh
there there's other breaches that take
place where things are worse the
attackers get things that are not easy
to change i'll talk about that in just a
second
with regards to the jpmorgan chase
breach what was stolen
was 70 million plus customer names and
email addresses
and by the way for a bank you'd imagine
they they
manage a lot of money they manage
trillions of dollars of assets in some
cases at least hundreds of billions of
dollars of assets
and it was at least good that no money
was stolen directly at least
but what what happened is when their
customer list of
70 million names and email addresses got
stolen it opened up those customers to
potential spear phishing attacks
when phishing attacks used to take place
on the internet
cyber criminals used to send out tons of
emails
purporting to be from a bank and hoping
that some of the recipients
would be customers of the bank and would
click on a link and go
log into an imposter site and then the
attackers could use the stolen
credentials
to then try to steal money but in this
case when you've got the entire list of
say jpmorgan chases customers you can
send out much more targeted spear
phishing emails
because you know that they are customers
of the bank how did this breach occur
well it was a case where there was
also a third party involved and
in particular there was a company by the
name of simcoe data systems that
ran a website that jpmorgan chase used
to
run and administer their charitable
marathon races
on an annual basis attackers had
compromised a website certificate for
simcoe data systems
and were able to get access to a whole
bunch of passwords
that jpmorgan chase employees were using
to log in
to to that charitable marathon race site
unfortunately many of them use the same
password
for that site as they did for their
corporate
banking systems and so attackers were
able to
to use that now jpmorgan chase
was spending over 250 million a year on
their
security and had two-factor
authentication
deployed almost anywhere two-factor
authentication is of course
that service which sends you a say a
six-digit code to your cell phone
uh when you log in so that even if
attacker is stolen your password
if they haven't also compromised your
cell phone they shouldn't be able to get
in
and jpmorgan chase had two-factor
authentication deployed
almost everywhere there was one server
that did not have two-factor
authentication deployed and so
the attackers that were able to take
over
that that website and get access to
passwords were able to log
in as jpmorgan chase employees
uh without having to do the two-factor
authentication because it just simply
wasn't enabled on one server
so uh that's what happened in in in that
breach
uh so what i'm gonna do is i'm gonna
speed up um i'm gonna talk about the
the jpmorgan chase uh i'm sorry i talked
about you or just already gonna talk
about the office of personnel management
breach
in 2015 um while the
breaches against target and j.p morgan
chase
were mostly suspected to be cyber
criminals the office of personnel
management
breach was one in which it was
attributed
to a chinese-funded
government attack in which
the identity information for over 20
million
government employees were stolen most
government agencies
used the office of personnel management
as their
human resources database if you will and
i think
most agencies except for maybe the cia
were using this
and the attackers uh broke into
the office of personnel management they
were they were not using
two-factor authentication uh very
aggressively
they were under investing in their
security program
they had they were only spending seven
million a year whereas even the
department of agriculture was sending
over 70 million a year
and so it was a case in which they they
failed to
prioritize security aggressively enough
fail to invest in security and failed to
execute on cyber security initiatives
like deploying two-factor authentication
aggressively enough there were a bunch
of
very sensitive systems that stored not
only the identity information but also
fingerprints
for a number of these government
employees and what happened
in the breach is that attackers
were able to exfiltrate uh that data
without being detected there were
actually two sets of attacker groups
and when the opm was notified by the
the us computer emergency response team
that they were they were under attack
they identified a first set of attackers
and took steps to
kick kick them out but they were unaware
that there was a second
a potentially affiliated attacker group
that was in as well so you know when you
when you
when you have a system where you have
attackers in there
you need to kick them all out at the
same time because the second that the
attackers catch win that you're on to
them
they can then work to steal
data they can stop their operations
around growing their footprint in an
organization and they can just steal
data
so opm attempted to to kick out that
first set of attackers in
what they call the big bang but because
they were unaware there was a
there was a second set of attackers also
in they were unable to stop them in time
uh in in the aftermath of all this it
was identified that
uh one in five of the devices
um at opm were infected with malware
and uh you know i talked about the the
say technical root causes of breach
earlier but
three metal level causes of reach are if
an organization doesn't
prioritize invest in and execute on
cyber security initiatives
uh correctly and aggressively enough
then then you can still get reached
so that's the office of personnel
management it was probably one of the
largest nation-state-oriented
attacks um the very next year though
it became apparent that yahoo had been
significantly compromised by uh
four russian attackers two xfsp agents
in which what the attackers did is they
they used malware and phishing attacks
to get in
to make their initial compromise but one
of the interesting things that they did
is that they and one question is okay
even if they got in and stole a database
of say 500 million
usernames and passwords or uh or a
billion usernames and passwords
uh question is how do they get access to
all three billion yahoo accounts the way
they did that
is they reverse engineered yahoo's
cookie generation scheme
so as we know when we go to a website we
enter a username and a password
once you're authenticated once your
credentials are checked
then you're given a authentication
cookie
and your browser caches that and really
it's that authentication cookie
that goes back and forth between the
browser and the server that
authenticates you so that you don't have
to type in your username and password
on every page for those of you that are
familiar with the http protocol
that's used to run the web it's a
stateless protocol and so
you you the cookies are used to manage
um
consistent state in web sessions so
basically once the attackers were able
to
reverse engineer the cookie generation
algorithm for yahoo
then they were able to log into any
yahoo account
at will just knowing the email address
for the account largest breach in the
history of the internet at the time
and at the time that the breach was
getting revealed to the market yahoo was
in the process of getting acquired by
verizon
verizon dropped their acquisition price
from i think
4.8 billion to 350 million less than
that
in the in the aftermath of the breach um
so you know some of the root causes
we've seen before but what was unique is
that they stole the cookie generation
element
so how your website generates cookies is
of extreme
critical importance and i think it's
important to to reuse
techniques and technology that have just
been vetted and uh
you know looked into over time you know
if you're interested in the details of
that
we have a course on the foundations of
information security
and we have another course on the um
the on on protecting and exploiting web
applications and there's more about
about that
uh let's see it's not only uh it's not
only email accounts that got stolen and
by the way when an email account gets
stolen
those email accounts can very often be
used to log into to banks or other
things
so it's it's it can just be worse than
email
it is important to practice email
because it's kind of the center of
communications for a lot of things
the very next year there was the largest
credit record related breach that took
place
at equifax for those of you that
may have may have heard of this breach
you may have heard that there was a
they were using an apache struts server
that's used in software
development and there was a
vulnerability in the apache strut server
that was
the world was kind of notified about by
apache but
uh equifax wasn't able to patch that in
time
but that was just the the very beginning
of it um
you know in my book i talk about how the
initial compromise took place
uh just within within a few days of the
of the vulnerability
becoming known to the world there were
a bunch of uh requests from chinese ip
addresses
that were probing the vulnerable apache
strut server
and seeing whether or not they could be
exploited
uh the security team at apache and the
security team at equifax attempted to
notify
many parts of the organization about the
um about the need to patch
but they had they had false negatives
and their scans there were a bunch of
uh you know more detailed issues but
once the attackers were able to
to leverage that vulnerability actually
a full two months later
the service still not being patched they
were able to
start probing databases
in equifax's network because it was a
relatively flat num
network and there were something like 40
or 60 databases that were accessible
from the compromise strut server
there there was also a number of other
vulnerabilities that were used uh
the attackers dropped 30 different uh
web shells or back doors
into the environment at equifax and in
fact
took advantage of sql injection they
planted a
a server page into a web application
that was accessible and use that to
exfiltrate data out of at least one of
the databases
so there were a number of things that
that went wrong even though the apache
starts vulnerability is
what was talked about mostly uh in the
press
let's see um
facebook has had a number of hacks and
breaches over the years actually in
the corresponding chapter in my book we
talk about 10 distinct
security incidents at facebook i don't
have the time to go
into all of them but i think
most of you may have heard of the
cambridge analytica
issue in which a third party
developer abused facebook's apis
and stored data about
uh from tens of millions of profiles
and then that data was used to advertise
and target voters in swing states to
influence the 2016 election
uh that particular um
you know that that particular issue was
was not a breach it was a hack
uh there were there were other issues as
well where
um uh you know russian interests
had abused additional features on the
facebook service
to influence voters uh
and so there's been a lot of that that's
been talked about but what i'm going to
do is delve into one
one item at facebook that was actually a
breach uh
announced in 2018 on facebook there is a
feature that allows you to view your
profile
not as yourself when you're logged in
but
allows you to see what your profile
looks like when the general public looks
at it and that
that particular feature is called view
as so on my
facebook author page it has this button
here that says view as visitor and when
i click it
it um hides a bunch of the menus and it
hides information that i just kind of
keep to myself i want to keep the valve
but this particular feature was abused
in a
pretty sophisticated in a pretty
sophisticated attack
which took advantage of three distinct
software vulnerabilities
and this attack occurred after facebook
locked down their apis so that
third-party developers could not
abuse their service as as easily
and let me just talk a little bit about
how that happened
facebook has a very nice blog post and
their security team put up a a great um
kind of post mortem and description of
how this breach occurred let me talk
briefly about
the three vulnerabilities that came
together so
on the uh you know with the view as
feature
there was a piece of functionality which
allowed
people to wish their friends happy
birthday
and there was a
feature that allowed one to post a video
as part of that as part of that widget
that allows you to wish your friends
happy birthday
it uh it incorrectly provided the
opportunity to post a video that was the
first issue
the second issue was that a a new
version of that video uploader
that was incorrectly provided access to
what it did is it gave more broad
permissions
to the viewer
than it should have and then the third
thing that went wrong
is that when it generated an access
token
to to allow someone to view the profile
it didn't generate an access token that
would allow them to just view your
profile
but rather it generated the wrong token
it generated an access token
for the user that was being looked up
and that
as if i understand it correctly also
gave
both not only read access but also write
access to the profile
and so there were tens of millions of
facebook profiles that were
scraped due to this set of three
vulnerabilities that came together you
know in many breaches it's just one
vulnerability that's used to get in
uh but this was this is pretty
sophisticated and i would i would
suspect that this would have been
conducted by a nation state
who wanted to get at the profile
information after facebook had
locked down a bunch of their apis so i
thought that was particularly
interesting uh there's been additional
uh big breaches
uh in the case of myriad also in in 2018
they had a breach in which
malware was used aggressively marriott
acquired starwood
which together with both hotel companies
made marriott the largest
hotel company in the world and in this
particular
case what happened is that there was an
undetected malware attack at starwood
that happened four years before
marriott's acquisition of starwood even
closed and was only discovered
later on and uh so without without
getting into
the technical details of malware which
is super interesting
uh i i'll just mention that when you
we've talked a little bit about third
party breaches right third party
compromises
the thing to keep in mind is that when
you think about third parties
don't think only about suppliers
companies that you buy software from for
instance
you have to think a little bit more
broadly than that so when you're
acquiring or thinking about acquiring a
company
that company they're thinking about
acquiring is initially a third party
and they need to be not only vetted
like say a supplier but need to be
vetted in a more
rigorous fashion than any potential
supplier because
uh after the acquisition closes
that third party company becomes a first
party company it becomes part of the
first party and so
if that third party is breached and you
acquire it you are breached too
so what's really important even even in
public companies is
while these things can be very sensitive
when one company is acquiring another
it's really important to make sure that
the security team
has a heads up and has the opportunity
to vet
that acquisition not only by doing
things like penetration testing
and reviewing their audits and stuff
like this
but also doing proactive threat hunting
you want to make sure
that they have not been breached and
just
don't know that they've been breached
and that's what what happened here
in 2019 what occurred was the capital
one breach
which was probably one of the largest
cloud security breaches to date capital
one
is known for aggressively using the
cloud and using
amazon web services specifically and
when you use
amazon web services um the
the they they do a lot to protect the
infrastructure
but you are still responsible for the
security of your applications
running on that infrastructure and what
happened in the case of the capital one
breach in 2019
is there was a single loan attacker so
it was not a
nation state it was not a cyber criminal
group it was a single
x employee who happened to have
technical knowledge about how the cloud
worked
but um didn't even have any insider
knowledge
and was able to identify that
capital one's uh servers one of their
ec2 instances uh one of their virtual
machines running on
on the amazon web services platform had
a vulnerability called the server side
request forgery vulnerability
and and that vulnerability combined
together
with um a set of permissions
on some s3 data buckets that were used
to store over 100 million
credit applications uh were were were
stolen
and i've given past webinars on on this
particular one where i've delved in
much more deeply uh so you can check
that out we also by the way do have a
cloud security course that will be uh
launching in the coming months and uh
you know the details around us will be
covered
uh much more in depth what i want to do
is
uh in terms of the last uh hack that
i'll cover i want to cover the
solarwinds hack
uh which occurred just this past
december
this is interesting because it was a
third party compromise where solarwinds
was a third party
and they were leveraged
to and sees the us department of
treasury the u.s department of commerce
uh department of homeland security
department of justice there were
over 3 500 email accounts
that attackers were able to get a view
into
attackers were also able to steal um
some attack tools from fireeye they were
able to and by the way
credit to fireeye for for discovering uh
this this particular attack and letting
solar winds know and letting the
community know uh if they hadn't
discovered it the pieces might have
eventually gotten pieced together but
fireeye is known for their very deep uh
forensics capabilities
and uh threat hunting capabilities and
so they they put that to use to identify
that um solarwinds
software was getting used and so to
hack into other companies solarwinds has
over 300 000 customers
and they have a product called orion
that was uh used by a number of those
customers
and their their product got taken
advantage of
attackers injected malicious code into
the product in a very sophisticated way
they
they infiltrated the build process such
that while a compilation
of their products were going on there
was a piece of malicious code that was
injected
uh and then after the binary was built
the
uh malicious file was removed and the
original one was put back to make
everything look normal
so it was pretty it was pretty
sophisticated in terms of that aspect
and um there were 18 000 companies that
could have potentially received the
malicious code update out of those 18
it's been identified that 100 private
sector companies
uh had the malicious code pushed to them
and had
compromises uh in addition to the to the
nine government agencies
so what was the impact of this well i've
talked about some of the things that
were
stolen um but the full impact of it
is is is yet to be determined you know
when this
when this uh solarwinds hack occurred
there were some that were comparing
the hack to a digital pearl harbor
and and that is a that is a
characterization that i i disagree with
for a bunch of reasons
uh first um pearl harbor was a complete
surprise
the solarwinds hack for for those of us
that have been in the field
uh not a complete surprise because
third-party compromises
we've seen many of them before as i've
talked about some of those already
target jp chase etc
um so so so so third-party compromise
not a surprise uh foreign nation-state
attacks
not a surprise as well if we look at uh
if we look at um
russian suspected russian-sponsored
attacks yahoo's
the largest uh you know breached in
terms of the number of
accounts affected and so not a surprise
that there's a nation-state behind this
uh and it's also not a
not a so not a surprise but also when
when you look at digital when you look
at pearl harbor all the carnage
of pearl harbor was immediately visible
the day of and the day after
whereas in a cyber attack like this
what the full implications are going to
be
may still not be understood for for
months
or more uh when the when the office of
personnel management
breach occurred back uh in
the 2015 2014-2015
time frame the kind of quotes that came
out
in the congressional hearings
surrounding that basically said that the
counterintelligence impact of that
breach
would affect efforts for at least a
generation
and may never fully be known
and i i would take a guess that
there might be similar issues at work
here
in any case uh the the solarwinds
hack is interesting by the way let me
also just reiterate that
while this hack has been called the
solarwinds attack
30 of the victim organizations
don't use solarwinds at all and the fact
that it's called the solarwinds hack may
just be a nature of
the order in which the discoveries have
taken place
so because fireeye did use solarwinds
and identified that there was an issue
that came through the solarwinds ryan
product
after that there was a whole bunch of
victims which
have been identified to be part of the
same overall attack
but don't use solar winds at all and i
think
what solarwinds has done is it has
sensitized us it's probably the first
third party compromise in which there
have been so many end targets
that have been have been uh taken
advantage of and by the way the the
third reason that i
i disagree with the digital pearl harbor
characterization
is because it appears that the goal of
the attacker here
was most likely espionage to get
information
and steal information but not
say commit an act of war in which you're
working to to harm people or
whatnot um so i think that there was a
lot of dust in the air
post the announcement of this hack uh
and some of the some of some of the
pictures getting clearer especially
uh after the the hearings this past
friday
but i think there's still going to be a
lot more to learn and i think that the
key issue that it's sensitizing us all
about
is that the security
of our software supply chain is
very important if
an attacker is able to infiltrate any
party along the
third party supply chain they can
target the end organizations and they
can do it in very
very stealthy ways uh the the solarwinds
attack
was um what was first
uh it first started taking place in in
late 2019
uh malicious codes started getting sent
out i believe in march 2020
and happened for a few months and the
attack didn't get discovered
uh until december 2020 by
one of you know the top forensics
players in the field fire eye so this
was this was uh
very interesting from many perspectives
so in any case
uh that's uh that's solo wins i think
i'll i'll uh
you know now chat a little bit about uh
how can we look at um what are the kind
of right habits that we need to have
in an organization in order to uh
become less susceptible to breach so you
know in in the book
um my co-author moody albayadi and i we
uh outline seven habits for highly
effective security
organizations and you know for those of
you that are familiar with stephen
covey's work
on highly effective people you'll notice
that habits one and seven are similar to
his habits so you know his first habit
is to be proactive we amended that to
say you need to
be proactive prepared and paranoid and
uh his seventh habit is called sharpen
the saw means you always want to get
better right
uh we we term that embrace continuous
improvement and so there are some
similarities there but the
the the core habits in the middle are
very specific
to security what i'll do is just talk
about a couple of them
so let me talk about habit two being
mission centric
so security practitioners are
often very very focused on
mitigating risk and one of the
challenges in the field
is to get security and technologies
people speaking the same language as the
ceo
and the board and the more that
any cyber security initiatives can do to
help
grow a business the better so for
instance if you're
pursuing getting hipaa compliance
the higher order bit there the more
important thing
the why you're doing that is so that you
can enable a company
to grow and go into the healthcare
market
and deal safely with protected health
innovation
and and that should be say the primary
uh reason um uh and so
you know you don't want to be perceived
as oh you're just you know checking some
boxes here
but you you want to help grow the
business and the reason that it's
important to speak that language
is so that you can uh
you know also get more funding not only
to achieve the compliance
but to help with the underlying
countermeasures that you need to plan
put in place so it's always good if you
if you can look at the root causes of
breach
and look at what counter measures you
need to put in place and
then achieve this the compliance as a
side effect
of doing the good security work so i
think that
sometimes technology and security
professionals um
you know pursue their initiatives and
don't connect the dots to what the
larger business is doing and so on this
particular slide
we show some examples of talking about
security projects
where the dots are not being connected
with the larger business overall and
then some examples where they've been
rephrased
to keep in mind the larger business
context
another habit that i'll talk about
that's super important is to
always work to build security and
privacy in
it's very hard to bolt security on
afterwards it's kind of like
quality when you build a product you
can't say well i'm going to build a
product i'm going to launch it and then
i'm going to make it a high quality
product
it's kind of hard to do that because
quality is a inherent characteristic
of the thing itself that you're building
and the way to think about security
is that it's just a kind of quality so
if you don't focus on
building it in it's really hard to bolt
it on afterwards
as we've seen by the way with just the
the architecture of the the internet
itself
and you know in in one of our um courses
and one of our webinars or whatnot here
we
we we spend time interviewing vint cerf
who was
one of the inventors of tcp the
protocols that the
entire internet runs on and we would
talk to them about the history of the
internet and the history of security on
the internet
and how things developed and evolved the
way they did and
why and how how the internet has
absorbed more and more security
technology and countermeasures over time
but we also see some of the some of the
challenge uh with that so so the more
that you can build it in at the
beginning
uh the better the final thing that i'll
mention
in terms of habits is that as with many
things in management it's important to
measure security
just like you measure a whole bunch of
other things because
if you can't measure it you
can't improve it so focus on measuring
security
and there's a whole bunch of different
ways to do that there's a whole bunch of
different compliance standards there's a
whole bunch of
uh different assessments that you can
get i have a bunch of them listed on
these slides
some of them can give you qualitative
measurements like pass fail i passed my
pci compliance
uh and and their white box because they
look at uh internal documents
but then there's other things like
security scorecard and bitsight where
they're quantitative they give you a
zero to 100 score their black box they
they just look at your organization from
the outside
but they they give you an understanding
and then there's things that are in the
middle
where they're quantitative but they look
at things inside so for instance beast
and the building security
in maturity model um assesses how many
different
software security practices is your
organization using and that can give you
an indication as to the
level of maturity of your of your
software organization
so those are some habits to keep in mind
and i think that in addition to
using macro measurements it's important
to use micromeasurements as well
especially for the root causes of breach
any counter measure that you have for a
root cause of breach
and i believe it's important to
understand
what is the scientific effectiveness of
that countermeasure you could always
deploy
you know open source clam av
anti-malware
that's based on looking for signatures
of past known malware
but the likelihood that that is going to
be effective against
any organized cyber criminal or nation
state is is almost next
nil uh so so you've got to measure
things
like what is the mean time to detect a
compromise host what what are what
percentage of malware threats are
identified upon
first observation of any new malware
sample
attackers these days will target an
organization they will understand what
antivirus are they using
and they will generate a whole bunch of
malware variants they will run it those
variants through all the
antivirus tools that are being used
until they come up with variants that
are
completely undetected and then those are
the variants that they'll launch against
the organization
so you know looking at a study of you
know what percentage of
known malware is detected is may not be
as helpful as looking at
i mean that might be just with table
stakes you got to look at what
percentage of unknown malware
is detected and then as we talked about
in the target case
you know what's the what's the false
positive rate because if there's a lot
of false positives
it's going to dilute your actionability
on uh on actual threats and so it's
important to have high fidelity
detection right and and for each of
these root causes of breach you can you
can come up with
scientific metrics and measures that you
can use to evaluate the effectiveness of
the countermeasures
so in any case um those are those are
some things to keep in mind
um how do you how do you prevent
breaches what kind of countermeasures
should you use
on this particular slide i list just a
few examples for each of the root causes
of breach
what are some of the countermeasures
that you can deploy
and you know in my book i talk about the
trade-offs between them
some of these defenses are gold some of
these are silver some of them
are bronze and there's a lot more that i
could say say on that
but i hope i've i've had the opportunity
to
talk about uh key takeaways from
a bunch of the big breaches that have
taken place you know cyber security is a
wonderful field to
get involved in and get into you don't
have to be a master hacker
uh there's many different roles that we
need there's about a million people
working in the fields in
the united states and probably uh
there's hundreds of thousands of open
job openings
so please uh please uh consider getting
involved you you
you can apply a lot of skills that you
have
in fact in my book i have the last
chapter is about about how you can take
your existing skills and use it to get
into the field of cyber security
so uh with that i hope that uh
companies and other organizations invest
primarily to address the root causes of
breach
not get taken away by you know the new
cool security vendor marketing
don't focus on just achieving the
minimum compliance bar achieve the
compliance as a side effect
and i hope that the information here has
been helpful
in helping you think about how to
prioritize defense's
organization thanks so much neil that
was
fantastic we have uh quite a few great
sort of questions that came in
throughout the session neil
i think if there's not one that you want
to start on
i thought one interesting place to begin
is you mentioned a lot of the effects
of these you know the potential effects
of a lot of these breaches
or hacks but you've also mentioned
the full extent of those impacts we
don't know and we may never know can you
elaborate a bit more on that do
have there been any studies in terms of
increases in identity
theft or fraud in the wake of some of
these major breaches and if not do you
have
you know where where can we learn more
about what the actual impacts are on us
the consumer or the user
or the individuals who whose information
has been breached
thank you for that question it's a very
good one while i've commented that
there's been
9 000 plus reported breaches to date
there are companies that for instance
they monitor the dark web
for unreported breaches so when
people's um usernames and passwords gets
stolen
from organization sometimes they they
pop up on the dark web
and so the number of unreported breaches
is is
is beyond that um 9000 mark
uh and by the way with some foreign
nation state attacks
right their goal is to you know get data
on
say where where where when spies were
staying where
in in various hotels right uh
that kind of data may never hit the dark
web because a a good foreign
intelligence agency
will want to keep that close to their
vest
so you know i i would i would recommend
that uh you know getting things like
identity theft
protection is is important um you know
much more broad in scope than
things like credit monitoring for a
bunch of these things we just
we just may never know for for all of us
there is much more data about all of us
outside our homes and in tons of
different
uh enterprise and government databases
than there is inside of our home so um i
also apologize if this is a little
unsatisfying
we can only know what we know once
certain things get detected but i think
one should always assume that
you know there there's more out there
that we don't know has been has been
detected so
um you know when you when you plan your
own defenses for your organization or
personally
uh i would uh make sure that you're
always using you know two
factor authentication for everything uh
every online account that offers it uh
leverage iaf protection
um sign up for dark web monitoring uh
and uh you know the hope the hope is
that with with uh you know
the these companies that monitor just
trillions of data points and trillions
of data sources
whenever there's anything about you that
may that may become known
then you'll get to find out about it so
uh
so so it is it is a bit unsatisfying um
we we
we learn more over time uh i think that
um you know when i think back to my own
phd defense
uh i was i was asked about uh you know
prevention versus detection versus
containment versus recovery
i'm i'm of the opinion that one should
try to focus as much on prevention as
possible
um but given the world that we're living
in
uh we have to we have to realize that
there may be a lot of data that's stolen
and so detecting when that data
is getting abused is just as important
as prevention
thanks neil and i i want to be
respectful of your time and everyone
who's joining us today
i think one other question that came up
a lot especially in connection
solarwinds hack
is this whole issue of 30 third-party
platforms and uh
and the you know as they're being
compromised so i think they're kind of
um
there are maybe two two related
questions so
first i know and when we've had i think
it was when we had a conversation is
there's
is when you're patching third-party
software do you always want to just
automatically
patch all your software or do you are
there times where you need to be
more thoughtful when it's dispatching
particularly critical infrastructure
that you have
and secondly um well let's start with
that one and you know
in general in terms of patching and
updating third-party software what can
we do to prevent it and is there
something
maybe being more thoughtful as you
implement patches
so overall i think it is very important
to leverage uh patches and get patches
deployed
as fast as possible i think if we look
at the number of vulnerabilities
that are identified and that are getting
exploited by attackers
you know if you don't patch you are
leaving yourselves open
to being taken advantage of by any and
all those vulnerabilities
now the other side of this is that in
the case of solar winds
there was a certificate
that was used to sign a lot of the
software updates
and because the attackers were able to
infiltrate the building of the software
malware was able to get deployed through
a trusted
deployment source and so in that case
getting the patch could have potentially
resulted in you
getting uh compromised or infiltrated
um and and while that was the case there
i think overall
the the the there is there is much more
benefit in
patching than in not patching and i
think that what's going to happen
in response and reaction to the
solarwinds hack
is that there's going to be more
innovation and investment
into software integrity and the build
pipelines
so uh savakaram krishna who is the new
ceo at solar
winds at the hearing this past friday he
mentioned
that solarwinds is going to publish some
information about how they're going to
be defending their software build
pipelines so that attackers
cannot inject malicious code into their
patches which is great i hope to see
that and i hope to see a lot of
similar things in the in the field such
that
we can pretty much err on the side of
hatching as often as as we can ideally
automatically
and have integrity and trust in the
software patches that are getting rolled
out
thanks deal we're just a little bit over
time and there's still a lot of
questions but
i think we'll end there and that's a
nice hopeful note and we're looking
forward to seeing
what the future developments are in
response to the solar winds
i want to thank you for your time i want
to thank everyone who joined us today
for their time
we really appreciate you joining us and
your active participation
as i mentioned at the beginning a
recording of the session will be sent
out in about a week so if you happen to
miss something or if you want to review
something
you'll have that available soon thank
you neil and thank you everyone again
thanks pax for having me thanks to the
team at scpd
behind the scenes for uh making this a
great smooth session
and thanks to all of you who are able to
attend i hope that
you came in learning something at least
one or two things that you didn't know
before
and uh look forward to potentially
getting your help in fighting cyber
security battles in the future